- I dunno if it's 'cause I'm salty as fuck
about the Jets loss last night or what
but the energy that I'm feeling right now
is on a different level.
And I just needed to make this video
and this is for all my
homies that were supposed to.
For all my homies that were supposed to
become a fuckin' NFL star
but they tore two ACL's
and now they're 24 and they don't know
where their life's going.
For all the people that
were supposed to be
a big time fucking person on Wall Street
because they went to
fuckin' Penn or Harvard
or wherever the fuck
and their parents did it
and their grandparents did it
and they were gonna do it too
and be a hedgefund this
and own a fuckin' house
in the Hamptons that,
and they fuckin' hate it.
They hate everybody they're with,
they hate people that love money
more than fuckin' anything
else and they hate it
and they're 26 and they're
in the worst fuckin' place
in their life right in here,
even though they got fuckin'
zeros in their bank account
'cause they were supposed
to be a fuckin' hedgefund,
Wall Street, mogul but
that's not their actual DNA.
For all my homies that were supposed to be
the next fuckin' hip-hop superstar.
They grew up with all the people,
they knew all the producers,
they were in the scene
and the clubs at 17,
co-signed by everybody.
But they just didn't
have that single talent,
or that song never broke,
or they got fucked along the way mentally
'cause they thought they were gonna win
and they didn't put in the work
in the studio, or on paper.
For all my homies that were supposed to
that are 22, 29, 27, 32, 34, 38.
Supposed to be a big time lawyer,
supposed to marry the girl
or guy of their dreams,
supposed to, supposed to, supposed to...
Can we fuckin' for the first time ever
have a conversation of supposed to to who?
Who anointed this supposed to?
For all my homies that were supposed to,
you're still young as
fuck, flip the script,
take control of your fuckin' life
and realize you have
it all in front of you.
There's so much to be done with this shit
or the world we live in.
Fuck everybody else's supposed to
and start doing it for your fuckin' self.